I know it's hard when you have kids and
there's a divorce do you think that your
son actually helped you but though cuz
at least having that little light in
your life like Gina I'm saying when it's
so dark and it's so do you think your
son kind of helped you get through
well parenting is a very it's a it it's
you have to be selfless I know so it
helped me in the sense I'm inside aren't
they so and they still are thankful huh
but what helps about that is that you're
just not always so self focused you know
you're like no I'm a mom and I'm gonna
I'm gonna do my best I'm committed to
this and that is a very healthy I don't
want to say distraction but
preoccupation that you love and enjoying
it does bring pleasure in your life
sense of course so it just wasn't always
about me all the time and I thought was
very very helpful and you have to live
to tell the story you know there's that
I don't even remember who this quote was
from but you know you've got to lift it
to survive to tell the story so the
hunter doesn't get the glory and
whatever it is that is has pounced on
you or is challenging you or weighing
you down you can't let it win you have
to survive and then it's so important to
tell the story to share the story so
you've got to survive to tell the story
and I just believe that that's a great
motto when you're I love that like what
about a shirt or a bumper sticker
reminding me every day that was really
great subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going